what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we we got ourselves an
official trailer for a movie I cannot
wait to see in the cinemas on the big
screen and that is from the Glorious man
himself our Saints the man who is solely
responsible for saving movie theaters
Thomas the Cruise's Mission Impossible
seven dead reckoning part one John good
morning how are you I am the gold
standard sir leave a like for John's
gold standard capabilities that would be
awesome also I gotta ask you guys a
question
why have you not picked yourself up a
real rejects exclusive space baby's
t-shirt thank you to everyone who has
gone ahead and purchased one hope your
bodies are feeling joyful I hope
Serendipity has reached your soul now
that you have yourself a real rejects
exclusive shopsteredition.com t-shirt
also over there we got a bunch of
exclusive apparel it's one of the best
ways to support the channel but what are
the best ways to support your epidermis
in total Link in description box and pin
comment let's check this trailer out
our lives
it is
for the sum of our choices
[Music]
Ronnie cannot escape the pass run time
Ethan the submission of yours is
impossible it's not a costume
chilly
truth is Vanishing
whoa
it's been a long time
you've no idea the power I represents
oh it knows your story and How It Ends
so much running
listen to me
the world's coming after you
activity
if anything happens to them there's no
place that I won't go to kill you that
is written
I'm gonna go off this Cliff yeah Kelly
you're all going to kill you
Ethan what's your objective
someone's writing ultimate objective
who's to accept it oh
sweetie
all the way back to the start
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I don't accept that
yeah
Tom Cruise Tom's sword fight
the train
[Music]
more chilly I'm like you I felt the most
like John Wick to me it really means
you're out in the desert and stuff like
that they're globetrotting well just a
lot of the locations of some of the Noir
Aesthetics to it the personal Peril that
you could feel in the emotional
undertones and the wide Ensemble but
it's just kind of funny that we had like
John Wick 4 which became like this epic
Ensemble action Masterpiece and then now
we're getting like the mission
impossible version of it because they're
they they feel like totally different
franchises but you can find like
similarities you can then you could also
kind of say the same thing about Keanu
Reeves and and uh Tom Cruise but you
know like Tom Cruise really does do all
of his own stunts where's Keanu Reeves
really loves to credit his stunt double
for for a lot of this genres even really
credits Tom Cruise
and all of these movies are decided over
bottles of whiskey no this was like a
really really awesome trailer I feel
like they're reserving a lot for the the
actual movie itself even though you know
we still got to see a bunch of different
shots and locations and all that kind of
fun [__] here too but this was bringing
back to me was a lot of that kind of
personal emotional intensity that I love
so much about Mission Impossible 3.
there seems to be a lot of Espionage
elements from the first mission
impossible as well that seems sort of
like littered through like throughout
this trailer not just bringing back the
kitchen into the fold not just bringing
him back there's and even the uh the the
thing with the Train on top of it which
excited me because you know whenever I
re-watched the first mission impossible
I do have the [__] off my brain like how
cool would it be if Tom Cruise decided
to just redo that but do it like really
yeah now with his full full uh Ascension
to stunt God yeah because while there
was some like real stunts to be had with
that whole train sequence you know
there's a lot more green screen Reliance
heavy there it is knowing who Tom Cruise
is today I wonder if they decided no
we're really really going to do the
train [__] but we're gonna keep it real
this time you gotta hide some of that
with green screen right like he's just
impossible to do all that practical I
don't know I I don't know crazy because
you got another actor involved in this
sequence here and just due to the factor
our moving train I have a hard time wrap
my head around that they could do it
practical either way it does feel like
an homage to the first one yeah I think
it's really smart that they're just
leading mostly with you know the globe
trotting Stakes the action the stunts
things like that I mean we know that the
Ensemble is capable and I like too that
we have the new characters like we see
glimpses of all the actors who are
joining the cast but you know they're
really leaving the surprise and the joy
of discovering how they all tie in and
uh you know for the experience of the
movie and I think with a sequel that
seems to want to hearken back to the
very first mission for Ethan Hunt Tom
Cruise that's a nice thing because now
it's going to get people going back
revisiting the first one in preparation
for this and two I know one thing I
think Christopher mcquarie said was that
they wanted to like his goal with this
was to take like the emotional Arc that
has you know developed for Ethan Hunt
over time and give just as equal amount
of character growth and TLC into the
entire ensemble basically give everybody
some kind of distinct Arc and some sort
of like really climactic sort of
character Stakes along with the
world-rending mission and that's
something I think will be really cool
too if they can nail it because like
they've built such a great Ensemble over
time and uh and yeah to see them all
kind of hey I have some kind of
emotional uh underpinning alongside all
the awesomeness is just a cool Prospect
and something that yeah if you're going
to do a two-part potential send-off I
think that makes a lot of sense too
because you know you get the stunt
goodness everybody can sink their teeth
into the acting and then if we you know
make a billion trillion dollars we can
keep it going yeah of course yeah yeah I
love so much about this trailer uh
because of the fact of how intense it
actually feels women Galore in here
Palm Clementi of joining the cast and
then you got Vanessa Kirby you got Haley
Atwell Rebecca Ferguson is what I was
trying to pull right there I wonder if
Monahan will make an appearance yeah
Michelle Bishop gets handy Newton back
in The Fray as well and Maggie Q
definitely bring all the women back
Paula Patton just get them honors some
other woman at the beginning here too it
looks like some personal death yeah yeah
yeah totally yeah we're going back to
what you're saying about Christopher
Corey that guy has a history with
screenwriting that it farce surpasses
you know cool action movies so you know
like his his Mastery of craft when it
comes to character development and
psychological uh attention and turmoil
it seems like we're going to be getting
more of that this time around which I'm
also very excited for ladies and
gentlemen what did you think about this
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
one trailer leave your thoughts down
below be sure to subscribe leave a like
we will certainly be doing a review
right out of the theater for this one
when it comes out
let's do a patron of the day shout out
Brandon Benzie your mission should you
choose to accept it is to jump from a
moving train and report back all right
you are here to test the movie Magic for
us all right is Tom Cruise full of it or
is he the real deal or are you the gold
standard I think it's easy to say that
at least you of all of us have to be the
gold standard you've got the perfect
comic book alliteration in your name and
if there was ever somebody I would be to
entrust an impossible mission too with
the most likelihood of success it would
be you Brandon you are strong you are
solid as a rock and I know that when uh
you know the when the S hits the F you
are not going to turn you're not gonna
be a mole or a rat or any kind of animal
poorly associated with impossible
missions and Espionage so uh yeah buddy
go out and test those stunts and let us
know what to expect from the realism of
mi7 part one
part two to follow anyway I love you
buddy stay pledged and that's the that's
the real way to save the world
you say things in these shout outs
[Music]